even though people seem to be still
digesting their food so but we'll start
so uh welcome back for the second
session today I don't have to tell you
about the importance of the assignments
and things like that right now but I
want to welcome
Etienne Padu who is well known to have
sort of studied function limits theorems
and things where we don't just have the
differential equation by pdas or
differential equations and if you want
to know anything about this
mathematically rigorous ACN is certainly
Z maybe one of the people but probably
the person to talk about so I'm looking
forward to your talk
thank you very much
thanks for the organizers to invite me
to this for inviting me to this very
nice workshop and giving me the
opportunity to present my work so this
is Joint work with Gordon Tong and it's
about functional law of large numbers
and PDS for special epidemic model with
infection age dependent infectivity
and the spatial could be thought maybe
as graph on if you prefer okay you will
see
okay so let me first explain the spatial
model so we consider a population of
fixed size distributed in K locations X1
XK and for Simplicity I says all the
locations are in the interval zero one
but it could be generalized
and let I and K
be a partition okay from one to capital
K be a partition of zero one such that
the interval I and K contains the point
x k
well I don't know sometimes I I I
probably
the end should not be there but of
course all these depend upon energy will
see and and for Simplicity I assume that
the lengths of each interval is exactly
one over k
now the individuals do not move between
the locations okay I have another work
where I study almost the same model but
where the movement it's more complicated
uh okay here there is no no movement
between locations so it's really like a
graph model and in it in the limit
grapher model so there are bnk
individuals in each location and the sum
of the b b and K's are exactly capital n
okay so in each location inverse are
characterized into three groups s i and
r so it's an sir model there is no loss
of immunity
like what we have seen earlier today
okay so as like susceptible I like in
infected I will discuss infected or
infectious uh in a minute and are like
removed or recovered
so we denote the number of individuals
in those compartments at time T and
location x k as S and K of t i n k of T
are NK of t
and for all T of course the sum
of those three guys for each case
exactly B and K because there is no
movement okay
so now we Define
piecewise constant functions of x
okay so instead of talking of S and K of
T I prefer to talk of s n of t x
which is that just a function which is
constant on the interval I and K
constant equals to S and K of t on the
interval ink the same with i and r okay
so I I want to think as those quantities
as indexed by T and X
okay so in each location there are two
types anyway there are three types of
idiots three compartments but now let me
discuss another point which is at Time
Zero
there are those who have been who are
infected at times zero those have been
infected in the past okay so uh and they
are I and K of zero of those okay and
all the others
and they have been infected in the past
and those who are susceptible at time T
okay they may be removed or recovered in
years at Time Zero but we don't need to
talk about them and they don't really
play a role in the epidemic okay so
those who are infected at Time Zero they
have been infected in the past so those
okay they are the index minus J is
because so for infections After Time
Zero there is the index of uh one two
Etc is positive and for the for the
infection times of those who are
infected at Time Zero it is before it is
is with minus J and this is negative
quantity okay this is a time at which
the individual J
has been infected in the past and he
still
he's supposed to be still infected the
time zero if not it would be of course
in the r compartment
okay and those were susceptible and may
or may not get infected later so get
infected means jump from the S
compartment to the eye compartment at
time okay now here this index is index
for individuals those individuals we
know how many there are and those
indices are for uh this is the first
time of infection of one individual this
is the second type of rejection another
idea Etc okay the the numbering is is
according to the increasing sequence of
infection times after time zero so
they could well they could but you don't
care
well they are
well you didn't write small it's not yes
it's not important to order them but we
kept in the orders
in a minute a bit later I will I will
talk about the the point measure which
with direct message those points okay
but okay whether they are not such
important in my yes
they could be
minus ik of zero is that correct
the number of yourself
so I thought you said there were no
rhythms
but
if they recovered you can just take them
out right yes and yes or no because you
you when you can't when you compute the
probabilities of the guy you meet is
susceptible you divide by the total
number of people in the patch in the
compartment in the patch and and then
you so the removed
appreciate
it should I think of if each infinitely
many characters in in advertisements
no oh okay you will see yes in a sense
yes but
for some moment it's fine you're being
inspired okay so now
for each J and K so K is for the patch J
for the
specific individual
it's okay it's okay it's between one and
capital K and J is either a negative
number for for those who have been
infected Before Time Zero or positive
integer and so J is runs in Z but not is
there is no J equals zero okay so those
functions along the J K are this is an
IID collection of random elements of D
of r with original plus so D is a score
space if you like you can think you
could say C they could be continuous but
because I want to include the more
classical models where Lambda is zero
and then jumps to fixed value and then
jumps back to zero I prefer not to
restrict to to rest those to be
continuous functions okay so they are
just cattle I mean right continuous ref
limits at each point so this is called
space okay and this satisfy Lambda of T
equals zero for all negative t
okay and okay so let me let me draw a
picture
so
okay so this is a time of infection
so
after the time of infection there is
probably possibly
an expo an exposed period during which
Lambda is zero okay you are not
infectious when you are exposed okay you
are infected but not infectious but I
don't I don't separate the compartments
e and I I could it would just add some
so another equation it will complicate I
I don't think it's very useful but I
could do it and then presumably I I
think of Lambda to rise rather quickly
to a maximum
okay for instance apparently in the case
of coffee this maximum should be shortly
before
the symptoms outbreak okay and then you
think that this decreases more or less
quickly and then hit zero and then it's
zero forever okay so those functions
Lambda they are random functions which
are IID and I think of those to be
roughly of that form but if you prefer
to have a jump to a fixed value and that
it's possible also or they could okay
they could they could have jumps and
then okay
so uh
and of course
okay in
here of course T equals zero is is the
infection time okay so infection time is
zero for this and so Lambda B zero for
negativity is just before the infections
of time the infection time of course
Lambda is zero
okay and then one important quantity is
the duration of the infected period I
don't see infectious because I include e
okay e plus I if you like I I include
the the okay so this is
here this
this okay this is a Lambda and this is
the ETA the durations
the the time from the time of infection
the time it takes for the Lambda to hit
zero and remain zero forever after that
okay so it's the last time that Lambda
is strictly positive
okay so at time Tau n j k plus ETA JK is
individual J jumps from the I to the r
compartment
right
I left this probability
good question
uh
I'm not sure what I need
I'm not trying to achieve anything
for the token today
uh okay usually okay by the way one
important thing is r0 what is r0 in this
model as you is the expectation of
integral from 0 to Infinity of Lambda of
T DT
which okay I will
later I will write Lana barov t for the
expectation of Lambda of T so it's just
the integral from 0 to Infinity from the
above tdt okay so now usually you expect
r0 to be finite
uh I mean for most this is it's more
reasonable
and and
I expect
ETA to be to be finite almost surely but
uh whether it's I know I'm not sure it's
really important in my case
it's the index J and K should we are
they related to these location or is it
just too arbitrary okay is related to
the location of course K is the location
and J refers to different individuals
this thing is diverse but
so or not this is an independent oh
because they are IID so the same row
so it doesn't depend okay I should of
course I should write it along the JK
but then the expectation doesn't depend
on GK
[Laughter]
so by the way uh
there is a question whether the law or
certainly you want you want the longer
JK to be IID when you bury J should they
should they have the same law for all K
I mean it's the same disease but
but maybe the climate is different so
should the low be dependent upon K so
here the law is not dependent upon k but
then okay when I Was preparing this
stock then a couple of days ago I sent
an email to my grocer and I said well
why don't we take the role of this
developer okay he said well I said I
suggested this six months ago and they
said you don't want it
no first I thought let's start with
something rather simple but then I
thought why not okay babe okay that's
another question really
okay if it depended on Cave was on top
in an aperture Okay no Okay I'm not with
development kids and Okay then if you
okay then how you define r naught is a
fixed parameter I don't know okay that's
another question I don't want to discuss
because
okay so now something very important is
the total force of infection in the in
the population I mean in the the total
force of infection at time T in location
x k
okay of course
usually the total force of infection is
just Lambda times Lambda or beta
whatever you whatever you like to to
call it times the number of infected
individuals okay but here because the
infection it depends upon the Time
season since the age of infection of
each individual so the total force of
infection is the population is something
much more complicated okay so you have
first of total force of infection at
time T of those who were already
infected at time zero this is
the quantity of course those are
negative so it's t plus something okay
as the age of infection for those who
are already infected Time Zero is larger
than T and this is the age of infection
of those
uh who were infected after Time Zero
okay where a n of T is the number of
initial is susceptible we have been
infected on the interval zero T in fact
I could
I could have put here S and K of 0
because because of my convention this
Lambda is zero for negative argument
okay I could sum over all everybody I
mean or will get possibly infected
sometimes after zero okay
your first thing now might come
into position because
well because the Lambda of T minus Tau
could be zero
at times zero or the lambda's over
here
zero it negative time
expand within there's only infections
within each location here no no no no no
no no no no no wait on the next slide
next I go too fast I mean I'm sorry I
need
now this is only the force of infection
with each side yeah
okay so next next we will see how how
the epidemic propagates okay so and then
again as for s i and r i Define f n of
GX to be the piecewise constant function
of X which defined from those quantities
okay
no
no no comes what Tom wanted me to
explain it very first okay let's p denot
a pkb did not measure individual oops
oh that's right that's great that's
great that PK did not beat your
Independence so that person processes so
wait one personal processes usually I
don't like to use time change personal
process I prefer to use integral respect
to a personal model measure or not to
plus but I I know that some people are
not used to that so I use it simpler I
mean for the proof it's simpler it's
it's much more technically it's much
more convenient to use a space-time uh
space-time personal measures but for the
exposition it is equivalent so so let me
do it like this so the number of people
who have been infected between 0 and T
in the location K this is a poisson
process time change by this integral
where Epsilon and K of T is okay so is
so you see there is there is infection
from all other sites okay so you have
you take the force of infection in the
side K plus K Prime
you multiply by the coefficient beta and
k k Prime you sum over K Prime there is
this normalizing constant which is the
length of the intervals and then you
multiply by the probability that the
person you encounter in location in the
patch K is receptible okay the
proportion of setibility time T in the
page in the patch k x k or whatever
okay so this is the rate at which the
epidemic
propagates in patch k
that's that's a data and KK Prime is
this is a matrix of positive curve
coefficients or non-negatives some of
them could be zero maybe you don't maybe
you never in fact from very far away
You're maybe only in fact from
neighboring sites I don't know or maybe
they are maybe it's a graph and you have
you have a
or in fact a long sum of the edges of
the graph not all edges so this need not
be those questions did not be all
positive some of them can be zero but
this tells you roughly a switch rate or
infection from K Prime to K yeah that's
the spatial structure it's a special
graphs that's fracture yes it kind of
has like a reaction diffusion because
within the patch there's the dynamic
identified and this is kind of this like
this is the flow within K from all
the alternates
I guess I mean like this probably this
flow is not really based on
um context bumping into each other per
se it's really just by neighborhood
structure of a graph of decaying patches
maybe okay for instance
for instance
okay suppose you live somewhere and
every day you move to another place for
work or maybe on weekends or vacation
you go to visit your family or you go
for vacation in some place and you are
infected and maybe in fact people in
another in this other place while you
are visiting
but you are visiting and then you come
back home so
I have no idea how to model these
movements of going somewhere and coming
back home
by by your usual you know movement uh
mother of movement so I prefer to say
this is infection that distance oh it's
not really
[Applause]
yes
okay
Okay so
that's it and finally
now we want to do to do a little more
this is this will be for the PD part of
the talk at the very end so we want to
define the number of infected
individuals at location x k and time T
who have been infected for duration less
than a
okay
this is the age of infection okay so you
take all the initially infected levers
whose age or infection
is
less than less than uh a so so if you
like T minus this is less than a
and then all those will have been
infected between time zero and Time and
Time t with age infection less than a so
this means that you stop the sum the you
sum the summation at this point at A and
K of T minus a plus plus one
okay and then again these function now
of two parameters GA becomes a function
of three parameters when I I
consider this as a piecewise constant
function of x
Okay so
now the stochastic finite population
model
so we have s i r so s n
of t x is s n of 0x minus
oops very sorry this is a this could
this should be a n of TX okay those who
have been infected between time zero and
time t
okay so maybe I write it here so the
correction of the
the wrong formula is
s n of TX
is s n of 0x
minus a n of TX
okay and then
and then the infected ones
those who
were infected at Time Zero but are still
infected the time T because that sum is
larger than T and similarly those who
have been infected between time zero and
time T and we are still infected at time
t
and then the recovered ones so you may
have recovered at time zero plus those
who have were infected but are already
were in fact at times zero and are
already recovered and those will have
been infected between time 0 and time T
and we are already recovered
foreign
X is ah
yeah right yes okay I should
yes you're right I have changed
so in the second and third identity
uh what is what is okay
anything which is indexed by K we should
have a sum over K so let's see a k times
integer function of i k of x
okay
so I don't know maybe I should get the
notation with k
okay
so and now
any quantity of course
of course this is the model but
as we will see later the really
important the two important identities
are this one and
and this
okay or and this and also
that one okay so maybe
so maybe I should
let me
you write
let me write this
so foreign
K of T no it's not g is f I'm sorry
and K of T the total force of infection
is sum from g equals 1 to i n of zero
of Lambda minus j k
of T minus Tau minus j k
plus sum from g equals one
to a n K of t
of Lambda g k
minus Tau and j k
okay and then
and then the next
button formula is a n k of T is P K of
integral from 0 to T of Epsilon
and K of SDS and the most important
thing is the formula for Epsilon
G of t
which is s okay let me write immediately
s n Bar K of T which means I've divided
by dividing by B and K means putting the
bar above s
times
1 over K sum over K Prime of beta n k k
Prime
F and K Prime of T by the way maybe I
should I should insist upon okay so you
see there are
in a way there are two parameters which
which
control or the the evolution of the
epidemic there is a Lambda okay which is
random which is assisted to each
individual which is sort of typical of
the illness
and there are those beta KK Prime which
are more like
describing
the the the the
the social contacts the the intensity of
the social context so for instance of
course the the
the diagonal terms in this Matrix are
very important they tell you about the
local infection local infection
important they don't need they don't
need to be all equal for instance you we
could say they are all equal to one the
the the
diagonal terms but I don't want to see
that because those diagonal terms
they can I mean if you are in a patch
which is uh uh essentially a desert or
in a patch which is New York City of
course the density the the
intensity of contacts is very are very
different so maybe you want to have
different betas okay
so this is this is really typical of the
illness the fact that the illness and
the way each individual reacts to the
illness so he is more or less and and
how long it time has evolved since
infection time the age of infection so
this gives you if you if you like this
tells you the probability when you meet
someone provided you to infect him okay
and and and that gives you the rate of
context between between the various
patches and inside each batch
thing which is still a little bit funny
so I assume eventually want to send Kate
yes
Alexander could just as fairly erase the
equation
[Music]
I think so all right yes
yes
interval is the case so okay maybe we
can already discuss that when I show the
final the repeating equations when
you're summing them up right
okay BBC is the limiting order
that's actually it's less of standards
are you assuming Mass actually is this
for scandalism
oh yes I'm dividing by n but in fact you
don't divide by N I divide by d n
okay
so each quantity whether this is f s i r
when I divide by b n
then I put a bar on top of it okay
and where b n is this b n of X is this
guy okay okay
I mean going from the K notation with K
into the nation of with X is just
something about K and putting these
indicators which which are missing on
those two lines I agree
okay now we wish to take the limit oops
m is busy we wish to take the limit as M
goes to Infinity
in this system and also in this guy but
I will first consider those
so the
now now let me State the Assumption main
assumptions
so the first assumption is as K goes to
infinity and N goes to Infinity the
infinity over K of B and K goes to
Infinity
but I need to assume
that the ship over those is finite
the soup of those ratios is finite which
means that they are of the the
the population size are the same of same
order in the different locations and
essentially then this just means that
then n goes to Infinity faster than k
okay
next we assume of course that the
initial conditions converge towards
appropriate limits namely okay the okay
see I will I'm always using in the X
variable I always use the L1 Norm okay
so in L1 you have you assume that you
have these those convergences
and if you I don't know those could be
deterministic or random the initial
conditions but uh whatever if it's if
they are random you need just to assume
that the conversion probability
now next I want the soup of those to be
finite
and I want
that uh
okay so beta and
x x Prime okay there is a sort of
confusion between notations but okay I
hope you
you you will allow me to to to
do that so beta n of x x Prime is not
exactly the sum of a KK Prime of beta
and KK Prime Times those two indicators
but first of all there is this
renormalization by one over K and next
I I need to put the the ratio here
because well UBC is a reason in a minute
okay
yes the duration is finally bounded so
it doesn't support the conversion so it
does make the conversion more okay and
then concerning Lambda those lambdas I
assume that they are bounded almost
surely by fixed constants
I'm not completely happy with this
assumption I would prefer to be able to
bound those by some random variable
which has some finite moment of some
order but that I I'm not able to to
prove the conversions with I would not
be able to prove the conversion with
those kind of assumptions
unfortunately
so there is this Bond
and uh Lambda has at most of a given
fixed number of jumps and this uniformly
continues between its Champs
and then I use net rotation to the bar
the bar for most quantities just
division by B and K but here the bar
means expectation
yes
does that mean that that sum there
is zero the two indicators multiply each
other are zero for all combinations
except one
there is only this one x max Prime to
which you have
foreign
yes so it just picks out the sound just
picks up which
so what you divide so picking up of that
so it's only equal to you only pick out
one time yes
one of our K goes to Infinity so is it
an Infinity Norm of beta n of x x Prime
goes to C is
thank you
yes but once you
know
I think this is correct well
yeah because there are many each cell
contains yes
so that's not just one
I have to think about this
your question disturbs me but certainly
the assertion thing is that I want
cases
yeah certainly I want this function to
converge to uh not zero function in L1
or maybe stronger than 50 whatever and
Maybe
maybe I don't need exactly maybe there
is an error maybe I don't need this
assumption but I need rather the beta n
is founded okay maybe I have to double
check
I'm sorry
okay so now
those are the limiting quantities
limiting equation
now I consider this system
of equations
and now in this system there is a new
limitation which is the distribution
function of the
of these viable data okay and FC is one
of the distribution function
Okay so
s n Bar of TX is S Bar 0 of t x minus
integral from 0 to T of Psi Epsilon bar
of s x d s I'm sorry the x is missing
here the variable X is missing F Bar of
TX is the contribution of the
of the initially infected Ninja Turtles
which is this
plus the contribution of the newly
infected individuals
which is the individuality of Lambda of
T minus s Epsilon bar s of s x d s okay
here I have the X but I'm sorry here I'm
missing the X two arrows
and then
okay and then the rest is here I have
not written the I above TX because the
IBO of TX is is certain from this by
choosing a equals plus infinity
okay so this is the the limit
the proportion of the
T of individuals location X aren't have
been infected uh for less than time a
and this is the density of removed in
the early time T allocation X
but okay what the the main message
is that
the important thing is this
system of two equations okay so this is
a system of equations with X is just a
parameter these those are integral
equations okay this is a an ode for each
axis is no d
ordinary differential equation
this is
this is uh an integral equation
because you see here you have Lambda bar
of T minus s so T is the same as this T
okay so it's not this is not an OD
this this comes from the I mean as soon
as you have a non you take the low blood
number limit of non-markovian epidemic
model you end up you don't have limiting
Audis you have integral equations or PDS
if you if you if you
put as a new variable the age of
infection you have a PD I will show you
the pde at the end of the top okay
well no the PSI bar the Epsilon bar of
TX is this guy S Bar of TX integral of 0
to 1 of beta of x x Prime F Bar of t x
Prime d x Prime
okay
Okay
so
[Music]
and you see not only
not only this is an integral equation
but it's an integral equation where you
have
I mean the equations for different
values of X are interconnected I mean
they are um yes when they are coupled
okay there is a coupling with for the
various axes through this integral
foreign
now the convergence results say that if
you compare S Bar N of t with S Bar of t
f Baron of t with F Bar of T and the
same with r
G etc those L1 Norms converging
probability as n goes to Infinity
uniformly interior in T and A where the
limits are given by unique solution of
the above set of integral equations
in fact
in fact
in fact it's in fact it's
one should rather say that we have a
system of two equations
we have a two-dimensional integral
equation which is that one
and once you have solved those equations
then you know S Bar F Bar you know
Epsilon bar and then you you compute
explicitly those I mean then you you
compute those quantities those
quantities are given from I mean are
expressed through the solution of the
system of the two first equations
yes
so we
do
so
infection dies on the out time t with
infinity
but we are trying to Infinity of fair
few infected people so how comes at your
law of large numbers
locally for me
oops I'm sorry
usually
I don't pretend I don't claim the typing
it for me
this is only local informative
okay
so essentially what you have to prove is
that this goes to zero locally uniformly
improvements
okay
so now the main idea of the proof is for
so I take the difference S Bar N minus S
Bar F Bar N minus F Bar
now I write
so
if you remember
so a n of TX was a plus an integral a
time change person integral I mean the
integral
personal process time change by the
integral of Epsilon n
of SX
so in fact this a n of TX is just the
integral of that guy plus a Martingale
term
and that martial term is shown to go to
zero as then goes to Infinity
now the other one is a little more
tricky
the other one though you have to compare
the evolution of
of I mean that difference which is which
is in the uh approximate model and the
limiting model how evolves the force of
infection due to the initially infected
individuals okay
this is not too hard but it is somewhat
to there is some work here
and then
and then in the f
you see
in the F again
you see the FN was this
it's written here so this you can write
as an integral of respect to d a n this
is this increasing function which jumps
at those times
okay
and and because the end is is almost PSI
n Bar d s plus I mean is prime r d s
plus uh Martingale the Martino term
which goes to zero here should go to
zero here also I mean it's a little uh
okay there is a T minus s here but okay
you can do it but also there is another
correction which is the fact that here I
have Lambda bar and here I don't I have
the Lambda okay so you have to show that
the the sum of the difference of Lambda
and Lambda bus goes to zero okay so the
all those correction terms I put in this
guy
and so essentially you have to show that
this goes to zero this is this is easy
because the second moment is of order
one over n that's easy to show
that this goes to zero it's a little
more tricky and also this goes to zero
and then all those conversions are in
probability in L1 locally uniformly
I know moreover now once suppose suppose
we have done this suppose we have done
this we should know that this okay this
goes to zero this is just our assumption
okay the Assumption says this this goes
to zero where we show it these and these
go to zero we show it and then next you
you have to to to use some
some estimate of those of those
differences and now the fact is that you
you look at the difference
Epsilon Bar N minus Epsilon of TX so you
have this quantity minus this
and now the thing is that you can show a
priori estimate of the soup over n t and
X okay it's always T less than or equal
to some capital T
NTN X the soup of this
you have your a priori estimate of this
tube and also that is in your stochastic
model you can show that this functions
this of course this is less than one
this is obvious now the fact that this
is bounded comes from the fact that the
betas are bounded the Lambda is bounded
Etc so it's not too hard to show disease
bonded
and then and then you look at the
limiting equation and you show that the
solution residency equation also has a
bound
I mean
not because it's a limit of the thing
which we don't know yet but but from the
equation you can show that April
estimates without before no even before
knowing that there is a unique solution
this is another thing we have to show
that there is any solution but this
limiting system of limiting expression
but before you know that there is a
unique solution you say okay if I have a
solution then it satisfies certain
bounds okay this is a usual techniques
for studying some
equations bees or D's Etc integral
equations and then once you have this
now you and and then you have also the
difference between minus beta equals to
zero in proper for proper topology then
it's not too hard to show that that
difference is bounded by constant times
by something which goes to zero which is
which takes into account the difference
between minus beta plus a constant times
the difference of those and plus one
times the difference of those two and
and then you can you get estimate and
you can show that the difference goes to
zero okay this is the main idea of the
proof
okay so now now I I go to my PD model
suppose now capital F remember the
capital F distribution is a distribution
function of the variable non-viable ETA
the duration of the infected period
suppose this is absolutely continuous if
a density little F okay it's not
absolutely necessary but okay but it's
better to assume this and then I Define
the associated Hazard function okay here
if T is a a bit okay yes it has a
function which is f divided by F capital
F C so it's a
okay Hazard function is well known in
some range of probability and statistics
okay so the rate at which you you you
you you get removed given that you have
not been removed yet okay essentially
okay so now assume that for assume that
the initial condition that initial
condition which gives you the the
limiting
uh
uh infection ages of the various
individuals at Time Zero
suppose this is absolutely continuous
and let's call
little I of 0 a x to be that the a
derivative of that function then for all
t a and almost everywhere in x
this is absolutely continuous
and its derivative
satisfy this linear PD so d i bar DT
plus d i Bar D A equals minus mu of a I
bar
okay
and with the initial condition which is
given of course this and some
strange strange looking boundary
condition
okay so this gives you the value at the
boundary a equals zero
which is this quantity
okay I've uh this a bar is because I
have not said that we assume that the
initially infected users there is a
maximum of age or infection of the
initially infected individuals okay so
which is able
okay so this is a boundary condition
now uh
the fact is that
what one can show is that this
PD
has a unique solution
you see this is the first order pde so
first order linear PD is solved by
characteristics so of course you see
that this
derivative means directive in the direct
directions parallel to the first
diagonal and so first of all we have
that the
derivative of the S Bar is minus I bar
of course those those who
those will get infected they they get
infected the time when they have
infection is zero so it's this formula
is quite natural and the above PD is a
unique solution given as follows so I
bar of t a x so there are two different
uh different
Expressions depending upon whether a is
larger than t or less than t
and for a larger than T you have this
fraction
times I bar of 0 a minus t x so this is
in terms of the initial condition a Time
T equals zero and the other term is in
terms of the boundary condition at a
equals zero okay
and
okay it's
the fact that this is satisfied does not
tell you that you have a unique solution
but you because you need to know the
boundary value but the fact is the
boundary value
is it's not too hard to show the Bandai
value binary function is a unique
solution of this integral equation so
the Bandai value
is uh is uh solves an integral equation
you see that on the right hand side you
have one okay you have this data this is
initial value which is a given data and
you have you have on the right the the
boundary value okay so we have this
equation
foreign
[Music]
use the microphone for questions
so there's something which I'm sort of a
little confused here which is that I
would have expected there should be some
derivative with respect to X appearing
somewhere it almost looks as if the
problem is just independent for all X
and you have no interaction so why don't
you get a pde involving X because there
is no movement in the X direction if the
web movement is yet Direction then I
would have a for of course A P or
peritone X
okay so for instance if the individuals
okay I have a parallel work where I
consider movement as a Markov chain
between the the sides in the limit I
have a diffusion and then I would have
the infinity generator of the of a PD
operator okay even in the in the
previous equation I would have a PD
operator
but so it seems you're better only
appears through your boundary condition
and doesn't really involve your
differential equations
so you have the initial condition and a
boundary condition and better of X and Y
only appears in the boundary condition
yes because
you see the infection
the infection produces Universe of
infection h0
and beta
explains the infection and the infection
produces doesn't produce in fact people
of infection age two or three or ten or
one others okay so I think it's quite
natural
and it's correct that the only way the
only way where that those uh the the
only coupling between the various values
of X the only reason why this is not
just an equation for for any fixed X you
have any question is is is through this
integral index Prime
okay
quick question um so the first part of
your talk you arrived at the system of I
guess equations that you wrote as
integral equations but then now you have
this proposition saying that you have
this pde right and so or how does it how
do you get from one is it just one uh
comes up from a forward argument on the
other from a backward argument type
thing or how do you get from this
no it's just that you you see you you
look at this quantity and you
differentiate it you differentiate with
respect to a
and the thing is that if at time 0 this
is differentiable with respect to a then
you when you look at this you see that
you can differentiate with respect to a
because a enters only the the uh
bounce of the integral okay
in fact okay okay this we have another
paper with the same code so uh where
okay we we have written several papers
or non-markovial models that are in
particular one on their infectivity
which has appeared in Scion I've applied
Mass last year and we have a paper where
okay and we in those papers we get
there is not this there is no a there's
no X of course there is no a and we get
those equations
and uh but
so we have integral equations
and somehow but there is also in
parallel literature where people
introduce PDS and so we said okay maybe
okay so there's another way of thinking
of the same thing you see here you have
you have the T minus s because you have
okay okay so we have to take into
account what is yes this is so to speak
this is infection H and this is what
happens at time T this is a contribution
or contribution of pass infection to the
present force of infection okay
but if you don't like
integral equations you can write a PD
okay however what is funny is that
somehow the way maybe there is another
way to do the same thing but the way I
understand that I can show a distance
uniqueness of this pde is
by writing an integral equation for the
boundary condition
about for the boundary function
okay so no references so these are the
past works with my courses so this is
the first paper where we had the
functional imagery of independent models
this is the orders paper but it appeared
only this year uh okay we have a paper
on where we use the the models like this
one to for the estimate of the copy the
epidemic in France
so here we have uh this is the first
paper where we study building products
with varying effectivity so with this
kind of Lambda appeared last year and
here this is a paper which where there
is a multi-patch multi-group epidemic
model with varying effectivity but there
is no occasion the number of patches
fixed doesn't go to Infinity like in
what I presented today okay so that
paper is going to appear at the end of
this year and then okay so somehow okay
first of all
this is very important paper which is
supported many many times
mostly by people who remind all we use
only the one particular case of their
model we fix we have fixed rates okay
and uh in fact in that paper the idea of
wearing effectivity was already there
not as random or infectivity but very
effectivity okay and by the way there is
the the next two papers by the same
authors Kendrick 3233 they considerable
severing susceptibility or immunity and
that we have done also very recently
okay and then there are those papers
Dickman Kendall and team which consider
a special spread of epidemic and PES
which are sort of similar to what we do
except well Kendall candle is for
machovian model so it's different
probably deep man and teams is closer to
what we do
okay thank you
okay
thank you very much more questions
so what was the role of your function
what was the role of your function
Lambda well the functions
where does it show up or does it shows
up in the
Force oh yeah yeah I see it this is the
part of the force of infection and
there's lots of infection and the force
of infection is essentially in the rate
of propagation of the epidemic I see so
so you can think of it as some kind of
load of the virus over the the time of
infectiousness
[Music]
that's almost
other questions
so let me just ask well it's more common
so to some extent work you have shown is
that in this patch model sort of main
field is exact right
yes
yes
well similarly what is interesting you
know in the in the paper
the these Scion paper we sort of recover
exactly the equation of kamakama
Kendrick from
stochastic models okay
no it's sort of have an interesting
comment is that uh
the two of us were discussing and
they're sort of looking at this old
model and we were saying somebody should
prove that actually it's a stochastic
limit and then sort of two days later we
actually found one of your papers and
therefore but you got invited to this
long before we had read this paper so
someone was a lucky accident and now at
least he and I can learn a little of the
details so this was very nice
thank you
so you said you assume that Lambda was
bounded I don't have a problem with that
at all but then did you make any
assumptions about it the the duration of
the Infectious period
I don't have any problem with saying
that Lambda is boundary that's perfectly
fine for me but then you also make some
assumption about hey that'd be you're
not really bounded or bounded in
probability or
I don't think I need anything like that
why do you define that
actually
why do you even Define it if you don't
make any assumptions about it
oh because when I want to disc oh why do
I Define data because exactly because in
order to describe okay
maybe it was here it's
when I want to write the equations for
okay here when I want the the equations
for i n r n then I know I need those
quantities okay
it also gives it the next page you need
the distribution function
yes yes
here okay for the same reason in the
limit not the value of all the buyers
but this efficient function of that from
the Bible they it enters the limiting
equations
no assumption
wait for instance well except if it goes
up to one and then it decays
exponentially forever then it is always
positive
I'm sure your results are still valid
yeah there is no then of course then L
Bar of TX is just L by zero of TX
and then I had one more question let's
see if I remember it yeah so the well
one thing is I'm sorry your model I I
would say your model is that you have a
process Lambda of T which is a
stochastic process yes that is sort of
given to you yes and then the other part
of the model is this Matrix beta beta
but then my question was well yeah so
you assume that the contact rate between
all of these patches are of the same
order so
I think in your mother you don't you
don't allow to have a much higher rate
of contacts within your own group it
cannot you cannot sort of have a a
contact rate of a different order on the
diagonal I don't think you're allowed
capital n
and I suppose you half of your contacts
are within your own patch and the other
half is with the rest of the population
I don't think it applies them that's not
a problem
as long as it's something given which
which doesn't develop an end you can
have a very different value no but you
have this supreme of a ratio was bounded
no but that was that was different
nothing to do the Supreme the Supreme
which was bounded okay it's here where
is it it's here
it's the it's not this there's nothing
to do with beta this is a number of
interviewers in each patch
because of the ratios as n goes to
Infinity is those ratio should not
explode none of this ratio May explode
so you mean that your limiting function
beta could be zero except on the
diagonal
okay that I that I have to think about
uh
I was just wondering because in some
situations you have sort of a
much higher rate on the diagonal and the
lower so I uh it was more like a
question is that kept covered in your
model or not I guess so but how far is
it covered I have to add to the website
thank you very much we just finished the
paper
a short time ago so
I have a follow-up question on that
you're better so it Con you're better of
X and X Prime converters in L1 but given
that you're better nkk Prime it's
bounded if it probably converts to a
bounded function right so could you deal
with the data which is not a bounded
function but which has some 1 over x
minus x minus X Prime to some power
for this problem it's not covered by
what we have done so far but so far but
I don't know whether we can go further
than what we've done
yes okay
it's a good question but
we have more sort of so far we have sort
of situations of beta's bundle
more questions
okay
I think this is kind of a similar
question I tried to ask earlier and just
because we're talking about the beta
still so I think that earlier in the
model like in the F and the a rates
they're very similar to sort of The
Chronic mckendrick like beta times test
times I based on the Dynamics right so
it's just a little more complicated
because the lambdas are not constant so
so that I kind of understand as like sir
interaction Dynamics but then the betas
between patches are kind of just like
there's new flow and it just starts with
brand new infections but it doesn't
really come from interactions it kind of
just comes from nowhere right it's like
a new new infection rate
you mean you could have at the initial
time some patches could be
free of infectious individuals no
epidemic in some of the patches and then
you have immigration I mean then then
you have then you have the epidemic
coming from outside of course this is a
load by this in this model yeah that's
what you mean yes
um yeah I probably should just ask you
offline yeah I'm just trying to
understand why we don't need beta to
appear in any kind of instantaneous rate
other than a boundary condition
so maybe
okay you call it special patches but I
could also access between zero one okay
so I could think of zero as I'm born
today and one is 100 years old and this
just uh age groups and you have
different racial infections between
different ages because the zero old ones
drives a hundred yards not so they never
see each other and they're sort of a
function of the age difference which
would
create contact so I could just think of
that as an inhomogeneous model they have
a continuous number of groups right I
don't have to think of them as
patches in space of course and and then
maybe that answers your question of
course in a sense in a sense we
that we thought of as graph on model
which is not really special
uh
okay so you get to close this English
question because we all want some
cookies
oh no we have hundred three right
so we have missed all the food but
that's fine
no you're sure okay
see you back at three yeah